حادثه عنصريه تهز قصر باكينغهام وتستنفر
العائله الملكيه البريطانيه ففي زمن لا
تمر فيه حوادث العنصريه العرقيه دون
محاسبه التراث العائله الملكيه الى التخلي
عن المساعده السابقه للملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه ليدي سوزنهاسي التي عملت معها على
مدى 60 عاما بعد استجوابها احدى الناشطات
الخيريه عن اصولها الافريقيه خلال حفل
استقبال في قصر باكنهم
من اين انا لذا اجبت انا من جمعيه سيست
سبيست انها منظمه تدعم الارث الافريقي
والكاريبي للنساء والفتيات بعدها قالت من
اي جزء من افريقيا انت فاجبت لا اعلم لم
يتركوا اي سجلات وهذه الحقيقه لم استطع
تتبع اي جزء اجابت من جديد لا من اين انت
قلت مركز فا
لا من اين انت بدات افكر ان الامر غير
مريح لكن قلت انه سؤال فاجبت انا من هنا
ولدت هنا نعم قالت لكن من اين انت فعلا
لكن هذا لم يمنعه من ادانه الحديثه معتبرا
ان العنصريه ليس لها مكان في المجتمع
البريطاني على حديقه
غير لائقه لكنه يعتبر ان رده الفعل ربما
مبالغ فيها بحق امراه تبلغ من العمر 38
عاما
هي منظمه عنصريه على الاطلاق اعتقد ان
الامور كانت خارج السياق قليلا والسيد
المعانيه ترتدي زي الافريقيه الوطنيه
او انه كان هناك بالفعل عنصري وافهم
الاستياء من الموضوع لكن على الجانب الاخر
اين ترسم الخط
اليس باستطاعه الشخصي ان يعبر عن ارائه
بحريه
83 عاما لكنها لم تكن عنصريه
بعد قرابه الثلاثه اشهر على وفاه الملكه
اليزابيث بدات مرحله جديده من ما قيل
ويقال بين افراد العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه هذه المره طالت اقرب المقربين
للملكه الراحله على خلفيه تصريحات اعتبرت
عنصريه وهذا انعكس شيء فهو يعكس عزم
العائله الملكيه على مواكبه التغييرات
الاجتماعيه والاستجابه للاهتمامات
والموضوعات التي تشغل الشارع البريطاني من
لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي العربيه